[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat et que j'ai eu le
plaisir de présenter avec brigitte
boucher bonjour brigitte bonjour ta main
est notre invité cette semaine pour
reparcourir toute l'actualité et laurent
saint martin bonjour vous êtes député la
république en marche rapporteur général
du budget et c'est brigitte qui brosse
est votre portrait laurence à martin
bonjour vous êtes né le 22 juin 1985 à
toulouse député la république en marche
du val de marne rapporteur général de la
commission des finances depuis 2000 19 à
seulement 35 ans vous êtes le plus jeune
à ce poste depuis le début de la vème
république
un record vous avez été élu en 2019 sera
donc votre premier budget à l'automne
2001 mais crise oblige vous avez déjà eu
trois projets de loi de finances
rectificative presque un record là aussi
alors en bon toulousain vous êtes fan de
ballon ovale jusqu'à poussé le vice à
devenir capitaine du quinze de france
parlementaires cette aventure vous
mènera ainsi vos collègues députés
jusqu'à la finale de la coupe du monde
de rugby au japon alors pour filer la
métaphore rugbystique est ce que vous
diriez qu'en rugby comme en politique il
faut un pack solide pour avancer et est
ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression vous
effondrez un peu au milieu de la mêlée
bon c'est une image que j'utilise
beaucoup dans nos réunions de groupes
effectivement celle de la mêlée et
savoir peu importe qui porte le ballon
dans un dans un mall un rugby peu
importe qui porte le ballon ce qui
compte c'est davantage avancé en cocotte
comme on dit comme on dit dans ce sport
et ce qui compte c'est d'avancer et ça
monte et ce qui compte c'est d'aller
derrière derrière la ligne et le ballon
en fait ils passent de main en main et
on se fiche un peu de qui là parce qu'à
la fin c'est une victoire collective et
c'est effectivement une image que
j'utilise régulièrement quand parfois
malheureusement politique
les tendances individualistes mais ce
n'est ni nouveau et ça existera après
nous viennent parfois à dépasser un
petit peu l'esprit un collectif c'est
une tendance contre laquelle il faut
lutter et moi au sein du groupe en
général du port qui venait certaine
attention et bien laurent saint martin
on va voir avec vous à bien les temps
forts de cette semaine le troisième
projet de loi de finances rectificative
adoptée en commission il rallonge les
aide de 45 milliards
euros pour aider entre autres les
secteurs du tourisme de l'automobile ou
de l'aéronautique pas d'accord entre
députés et sénateurs sur le texte
organisant la sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire les sénateurs jugent le projet
de loi attentatoires aux libertés
le gouvernement défend des restrictions
proportionnée des bracelets
électroniques pour des détenus
terroristes à leur sortie de prison une
mesure de sûreté votée cette semaine à
l'assemblée alors c'était l'événement
cette semaine à l'assemblée la
commission denquête chargé d'évaluer
l'impact la gestion et les conséquences
de l'épidémie kobe de 19 à auditionner
professeur didier raoult et
l'infectiologue alias eu de marseille
fervent défenseur de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine a été entendu pendant trois
heures au cours de son audition il a
livré à un réquisitoire contre le
système français en écoute je ne suis
pas d'accord avec la décision qui a été
prise de ne pas généraliser les tests et
c'est moi qui ai expliqué excuses au
président pour la première fois et qui
lui ai redit vous savez la pcr c'est
très simple et tout le monde peut faire
et donc c'est pendant tout ce temps on
n'a pas dit la vérité
maintenant dire le rang saint martin
quand on entend professeur didier raoult
est ce qu'on peut se dire que on peut
avoir un doute sur les failles de l'état
dans cette gestion de l'épidémie
vous présentez le docteur out qui est
une des personnes auditionnées par cette
mission d'information à laquelle on a
doté des pouvoirs d'enquêté qui veut
aussi qu'avec la combière par exemple
mais preuve en est que vous couvrez vous
même dans votre reportage la seule
audition de 10g route c'est didier
rahout est un scientifique pertinent
très reconnu dans son domaine et la
commission denquête ne l'a auditionné
que là dessus que là dessus
le reste le personnage médiatique je le
suis comme vous je suis un citoyen comme
vous il en face in certain il en fatigue
d'autres je ne prononcerai pas là-dessus
la seule chose qui m'intéresse comme
membre de la mission d'information même
si je vais devoir passer la main pour
des raisons d'agenda évidemment à
certains de mes collègues
la seule chose qui m'importe c'est ce
que monsieur raout à dire de la gestion
de la crise a à dire de sa propre
interprétation de la maladie et de ce
qu'il a proposé pour la soigner
ça c'est intéressant le reste à savoir
quels sont les passes d'armes entre me
sera ajouté la présidente de la mission
qu'elle est le ton employé par tel ou
tel collègue par rapport à didier rahout
m'intéresse absolument pas et si on ne
veut qu'on reste sur le fond laurent ce
moment est-ce que c'est compliqué pour
des parlementaires qui ne sont pas des
scientifiques qui ne sont pas
spécialistes de juger ce qu'il dit à
quoi ça sert ce type d'audition ce qu'il
faudrait pas avoir plus de débat
contradictoire mais peut-être des
sciences du tout les 1 face aux autres
et face aux parlementaires c'est ce que
prévoit éventuellement de faire la
commission denquête ya peut-être là ça
peut être une option mais quand vous
faites un débat contradictoire et il ne
vous est pas plus facile de juger qui a
raison mais vous touchez un point très
important le parlementaire n'est pas
nécessairement médecin il y en a mais il
y en a comme moi qui ne le sont pas et
donc nous devons nous avoir notre devoir
d'acteurs public de décideurs de
législateur pour comprendre
effectivement la lumière des auditions
ce qui nous paraît pertinent
quels enseignements peut on tirer mais
ce qui est compliqué qu'est ce qui
compte dans une commission d' enquête
comme celle-là c'est de faire mieux la
prochaine fois on sait de c'est
d'essayer de tirer des enseignements
c'est pas de savoir qui est responsable
qui a plus ou moins bien fait ce qui
compte est ce que collectivement dans un
esprit d'union nationale s'il ya une
deuxième vague et bien on peut
effectivement évité un confinement
généralisée et préparer différemment
cette étape cruciale qu'est ce qui se
passe il ya un nouveau virus dans
quelques années comment est-ce qu'on se
prépare différemment leur et qu'ils
ignorent quel livre est aussi une
histoire réquisitoire didier rahout a
répondu à des questions de députés ce
n'est pas un réquisitoire
madame lacombe a fait du même élan la
gestion des gars et on sait qu emmanuel
macron lui a donné du crédit quand même
en allant à marseille il a aussi vous
vous prenez un parti pris chez désolé
vous si vous écoutez l'ensemble de
l'audition de monsieur raout il ya
plusieurs plusieurs moments où il salue
aussi des bonnes décisions qui ont été
prises
le sujet c'est d'avoir un point de vue
par un personnage important moment de la
crise qui est un médecin qui a fait des
choix avec son institut dans ce taux
dans son hôpital on essaie de comprendre
ses choix
qu'est-ce qui a été utile à travers ses
choix qu'est ce qui a peut-être été
aussi problématique à travers ses choix
effectivement nous ne ressortiront pas
médecin de cette commission denquête
nous sommes là pour entendre pour
comprendre et comment est ce qu'en
termes d'action publique parce que c'est
ça notre compétence
comment est ce qu'en termes de
législation nous pourrons éventuellement
faire changer les choses pour que demain
nous soyons mieux préparé à ce type de
crise lé l'actualité c'est aussi le 3e
budget rectificatif depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
et de trois le troisième projet de loi
de finances rectificative a été adopté
en commission à l'assemblée cette
semaine il a pour but de renforcer les
dispositifs déjà en place pour faire
face à la crise et d'aidé plusieurs
secteurs en difficulté il donne aussi un
petit coup de pouce à la consommation en
étendant la prime macron stéphanie des
pierres c'est le troisième budget
rectificatif pour faire face à la crise
sanitaire devenue une crise économique
l'état débloque 45 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour les secteurs les
plus fragilisés comme le tourisme
l'aéronautique l'automobile ou encore la
presse je rappelle que l'ensemble des
sommes qui sont consacrés à cette
réponse à la crise économique représente
avec ce plfr 3 460 milliards d'euros
c'est 20 % de la richesse nationale
française
c'est l'équivalent du produit national
brut de l'autriche
c'est donc une réponse massive et je le
redis efficace qui a été apportée à
cette crise
en commission les députés ont renforcé
les dispositions de soutien aux
entreprises et prolonger la prime macron
pour les salariés jusqu'au 31 décembre
ils ont aussi débloquer 425 millions
d'euros pour les transports en ile de
france
insuffisant pour la droite qui gère la
région l'état a laissé pendant quatre
mois participer la région à l'effort
national notamment en assurant la
continuité du service public et des
transports en commun c'est-à-dire payés
à 100% les opérateurs la sncf la ratp
pour un service qui n'a pas dépassé 30%
et aujourd'hui et les discussions
préalables ont montré l'état le
gouvernement vous même sur le rapporteur
personne n'était en mesure de s'engager
sur une compensation intégrale
il devrait y avoir un quatrième budget
rectificatif en septembre car les
chiffres sont vertigineux
le pib est en recul de 11% le déficit
public passe la barre des 220 milliards
d'euros à laurent saint martin ce budget
sera t-il suffisant ou faudra-t-il
effectivement un quatrième budget
rectificatif au mois de septembre
nous le verrons bien les véhicules
législatifs c'est pas le plus important
de savoir si on a trois ou quatre ce qui
compte c'est ce que vous avez dit est ce
que
et ont assez et nous surtout nous
mettons au bon endroit pour que nos
entreprises maintenant puisse rebondir
ça fait quatre mois que nous sommes au
coeur d'une crise majeure
peut-être la plus importante que notre
histoire moderne est connue d'un point
de vue économique pourquoi parce que
nous avons arrêté volontairement par le
confinement à la fois l'offre
c'est-à-dire que les entreprises
puissent produire et à la fois la
demande en lice en demandant aux gens de
rester chez eux pour redémarrer tout ça
il faut beaucoup de puissance publique
il faut beaucoup dead il faut beaucoup
d'accompagnement et donc il faut
beaucoup d'efforts puisque la question
de la reprise nous avons bruno le maire
l'a bien expliqué 20 % de la richesse
nationale consacrée au sauvetage de
notre économie et à sa reprise c'est
colossal
cet argent on y reviendra c'est pas de
l'argent magique cet argent nous
l'empruntons nous nous endettons pour
pouvoir redémarrer notre économie mais
ce que nous disons c'est que nous avons
fait le choix de l'endettement pour que
notre économie reste vivante
nous avons fait le choix de
l'endettement pour qu'elle puisse
repartir et surtout nous avons fait le
choix de l'endettement pour sauver un
maximum d'emplois
c'est ça qui compte ça sera notre seule
boussole du foot il faut un peu la ferme
quatre pour sauver plus d'emplois je
n'ai aucun problème à racontez nous
votre homologue au sénat le berry de
montgolfier juge que ce texte ne
contient pas de vraies mesures de
relance il trouve que cela ne va pas
assez vite il veut des mesures pour
donner plus de trésorerie aux
entreprises stimuler l'investissement
des collectivités de débloquer les
pannes accumulé pourquoi ce n'est pas
déjà présent dans ce texte sale est
présent dans ce texte et albéric de
montgolfier le sait pertinemment 45
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sont
mis sur la table à travers ce texte dont
une mesure inédite qui n'a jamais été
fait dans l'histoire de la république
l'exonération de charges sociales pour
toutes les entreprises qui ont été
touchées de plein fouet par la crise
c'est à dire les secteurs que vous avez
bien présentés dans votre reportage
hôtellerie cafés restaurants mais aussi
tous ses secteurs dépendant de ces mêmes
restaurants et hôtels
ça va on a trop tendance en france
parfois c'est à dire en a fermé des
restaurants donc on va les aider eux
oui mais tout ça est ce matin à 6h moi
j'étais à rungis j'allais voir les
grossistes mais les grossistes ils vont
pas au restaurant ils ont pas de chiffre
d'affaires sinon pas de chiffre
d'affaires ils peuvent pas payer leurs
salariés tant que aussi il faut les
aider et cette chaîne de valeur
économique
c'est ce que nous faisons quand dans le
plfr 3 nous exonérons de charges
sociales à hauteur de plusieurs
milliards d'euros ce qui n'a jamais été
dissous qui constitutionnellement a mis
sous verre fils qui je vais venir mais
d'abord rappeler quand même le caractère
inédit puisqu'on est dans une émission
qui s'appelle parlement hebdo dire que
constitutionnellement c'est la première
fois que nous opérons une exonération de
charges et jamais le parlement de se
prononcer sur une telle mesure
alors maintenant effectivement sais pas
quel était votre question précise finale
et vous allez aider
que ce soit en termes de milliards mis
sur etam mais aussi de chômage partiel
et cela pendant deux ans la perfusion
est nécessaire à partir du moment où
vous empêcher la production d'être
produite c'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant ces sept semaines de confinement
maintenant justement l'enjeu c'est de
retirer l'action de l'état au fur et à
mesure que l'activité reprend mais
attention si vous retirez trop vite
cette perfusion dont vous parlez vous
risquez de faire tomber un paquet
d'entreprises et des emplois à la clé
donc il faut le faire avec prudence
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec albéric
de montgolfier quand il dit que nous
sommes déjà dans la relance nous sommes
à un carrefour
toujours en soutien attention toujours
en soutien avant la relance et la
relance et reviendra au courant de l'été
en fonction des besoins de chaque
séquence sur les transports publics en
ile de france on a entendu dans le sujet
robin reda sur le fait que valérie
pécresse réclame 2,6 milliards d'euros
dead pour ile-de-france mobilité elles
disent non et basse et la cessation de
paiement pour le 8 juillet c'est la fin
des transports en ile-de-france et le
gouvernement l'exécutif le refuse
pourquoi alors sur ile-de-france
mobilité c'est j'ai tenu personnellement
à porter ce dossier en comité la
commission des finances
cette semaine pourquoi parce que
ile-de-france mobilité se retrouve avec
un trou dans ses recettes important qui
est celui du versement mobilité de
versements mobilité c'est une taxe que
payent les entreprises à ile-de-france
mobilité qui est ce qui s'appelle une
autorité organisatrice de mobilité j'ai
dit au gouvernement il n'est pas
possible qu'il de france mobilité se
retrouve amputée de cette recette là et
il faut la compenser pour m au même
titre que les autres autorités
organisatrices de mobilité composé de
l'association d'euros elle demande deux
milliards système g c'est parce que nous
avons proposé avec mes collègues de la
majorité d'ile-de-france cet amendement
qu'il de france mobilité va pouvoir être
compensé il faut quand même le dire
d'abord
parce qu'il ya une volonté des députés
de la majorité francilienne de sauver
ile-de-france mobilité de lui permettre
de faire face à ces organes à vis de ces
opérateurs financiers c'est moi je
rentre pas dans une guerre de chiffres
ça ne m'intéresse pas de jouer un petit
peu au poker menteur de savoir si je
suis trop bas ou si valérie pécresse est
trop ça ne m'intéresse pas nous avons
fait des simulations sur la perte du
versement mobilité sur des simulations
fiscales
nous avons l'administration avec le
ministre des comptes publics pour savoir
effectivement
quelles sont les possibilités de perte
de versements mobilité ce qui compte est
ce qu'il faut dire ce sont deux messages
les usagers ne paieront pas par la
hausse du passe navigo cette baisse de
versements mobilité nous compenserons
systématiquement la baisse du versement
mobilité et si cette perte finale en fin
d'année venez être supérieur à ce que
nous avons pour nous compenserons du
tram et l'avons toujours dit comme cela
nous l'avons toujours dit comme cela le
versement mobilité finale perdue par une
frange mobilité sera payé par l'état et
je trouve politiquement un peu baroque
devenir reprocher parce que valérie
pécresse serait de l'opposition à des
députés de la majorité un amendement qui
est le seul capable de sautes villes de
france mobilité politique à un moment il
ya un moment l'union nationale ça veut
dire quelques faits la politique c'est à
dire que je proposais de sauville de
france mobilité ne semble pas faire de
la politique dans ces moments là il me
semble parler aux usagers pour dire que
ce n'est pas à eux de payer la note
allez on continue les missions avec le
désaccord qui reste entre députés et
sénateurs sur la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
[Musique]
la commission mixte paritaire n'a pas
abouti le projet de loi qui organise la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
prévoit une période d'entre deux pendant
quatre mois être restrictives de liberté
selon les sénateurs cécile 6 où il a le
goût et la couleur de l'état d'urgence
mais n'en porte pas le nom c'est le
principal reproche adressé par les
sénateurs de tous bords au projet de loi
de sortie de l'état d'urgence lors de
son examen en séance
vous créez quelque chose de neuf on
connaissait le droit commun on
connaissait l'état d'urgence et vous
créer une sorte de pseudo état d'urgence
à géométrie variable et a duré aléatoire
un texte de sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui reproduit les mesures les
plus importantes de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est un texte prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
de son côté olivier véran défend un
texte qui donne au gouvernement les
moyens d'agir en cas de retour de
l'épidémie personne ne peut dire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
le virus a disparu de notre pays
personne ne peut donc considérer qu'il
faille aujourd'hui nous départir
d'outils dont j'avais retenu des
précédents débats qu'il vous paraît
c'est à vous même qui avez rédigé ces
amendements suppression indispensable
dans la lutte contre la diffusion du
virus
limitation des déplacements
réglementation des moyens de transport
restriction des rassemblements pour les
sénateurs ces mesures sont
disproportionnées par rapport à la
situation sanitaire
la haute assemblée a donc voté lundi
soir un texte revu et corrigé moins
restrictive de liberté jeudi matin il
devait se mettre d'accord avec les
députés en commission mixte paritaire
mais elle s'est soldée par un échec nous
ne pouvons accepter des restrictions
excessives aux libertés a tweeté
philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois
le projet sera donc de nouveau examiné
par les députés mardi puis jeudi au
sénat avant une adoption définitive à
l'assemblée qui a le dernier mot
laurent saint martin la commission mixte
paritaire a échoué à se mettre d'accord
sur la fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui nous avec des mesures qui sont
prolongées quand même jusqu'au 30
octobre
c'est par nature un état d'urgence
sanitaire une restriction des libertés
est ce qu'on peut ne pas trouver
d'accord au parlement
sur un texte aussi important que celui
là je ne comprends pas très bien la
position des sénateurs là dessus juste
c'est trop restrictif de liberté et
notamment sur la question des
manifestations ces mêmes sénateurs
notamment du groupe majoritaire au sénat
considérer que les mesures pendant
l'état d'urgence était tout à fait
adapté à la crise il ne me semble pas
comme l'a très bien dit olivier verrons
il ne semble pas que la crise soit
derrière nous mais alors pourquoi l'état
d'urgence à nietzsche est tout
simplement mon sentiment est que nous
sommes totalement encore en vigilance
permanente sur une reprise possible de
l'épidémie une reprise possible de
sortie de l'état d'urgence du coup parce
que ce que propose le gouvernement c'est
justement de reconnaître que nous ne
sommes plus confiné que la circulation
de virus n'est plus la même mais qu'il
nous faut conserver des outils
nécessaires justement pour pouvoir au
mieux préparer un retour de la pandémie
et un retour d'une vague c'est ça qui
est proposé à travers ce texte c'est
plutôt honnêtement de bon aloi et je
suis sûr qu'au fond les sénateurs le
savent
tout le monde comprend bien qu'on
commence à faire rentrer un peu dos
politicienne au fur et à mesure et que
l'union nationale se craquelle par
endroits sur cette chambre à une attente
et dans ce texte et le avec le régime
que cette autorisation préalable ne
donnons pas ce texte de pouvoir qu'il
n'a pas ce texte d'accord vise à parce
que nous ne proposons pas l'état
d'urgence doté l'exécutif des outils
strictement nécessaire strictement
nécessaire à bien maîtriser la
circulation du virus et a bien anticipé
le retour d'une vague ni plus ni moins
c'est un enjeu sanitaire il n'y a pas un
sénateur de la majorité comme de
l'opposition qui peut nier que l'enjeu
de l'anticipation sanitaires et la
priorité sinon qu'est ce qui va se
passer
nous ne votons pas cette loi très bien
la vague revient l'exécutif n'est pas
équipé j'attends de voir la réaction de
ces mêmes sénateurs si l'exécutif n'est
pas doté des outils pour mieux prévenir
les prochaines crises au coeur en tout
cas des dissensions entre les députés et
sénateurs la question des manifestations
manifestations qui ont marqué
l'actualité notamment manifestation
contre le racisme contre les violences
policières mais aussi des policiers
qu'ils se sentent lâchés par le ministre
de l'intérieur christophe castaner qui
était auditionné jeudi par le sénat dans
le cadre de la mission d'information sur
les moyens d'action et les méthodes
d'information d'intervention des forces
de l'ordre on écoute le ministre de
l'intérieur ce que je veux dire c'est
que si comme je lai annoncé cette
technique ne sera dorénavant plus
enseignée dans les écoles de police
nous devons trouver les moyens
techniques ou matériel de substitution
pour que nos forces puissent intervenir
et dès lors qu'elles ont été formés à
cette technique je ne souhaite pas leur
dire c'est fini
du jour au lendemain et donc j'ai mis un
délai court pour qu'on propose des
solutions de substitution et qu'on fasse
une formation individuelle pour chacun
de ses agents dans le contexte que nous
connaissons
ça vise à les protéger donc
l'enseignement est interdite mais la
pratique est autorisée pendant deux mois
et en en deux mois et demi le temps d'un
substitut et la cinétique et personne
n'envisage de désarmer la police
l'enseignement interdit la pratique
autorisée ce qu'il ya contradiction
pendant au moins cette période de deux
mois et demi qui va rester où on pourra
encore utilisé cette technique de la clé
d'étranglement
non je crois qu'on est là encore don de
la mauvaise polémique tout le monde
comprend bien qu'il y à une transition
nécessaire forcément sur les usages au
quotidien de la police et donc des
possibilités qui leur sont donnés cesser
toute forme la pratique mise en cause
dans la mort du livreur cédric jovial
l'étranglement
écoutez le ministre de l'intérieur là
encore je vais vous faire un peu une
réponse similaire à tout à l'heure un
mini-centre a pris des décisions
courageuses
pas simple la preuve est un certain
d'entre eux effectivement dans des
discussions compliquées difficiles avec
certains syndicats de police sur ces
sujets là on peut pas d'un côté reproché
au ministre de l'intérieur de prendre
des décisions difficiles courageuses
parce que le métier de policier et de
gendarme est difficile est ce qu'il n'a
pas pas que leur demande et parce qu'ils
suppriment les leurs demandes venant
alors qu'il n'y a pas de substitution
c'est bien ce qu'on entend s'il vient
d'expliquer que si mais qu'il y avait
effectivement un délai de transition
le top-4 constitué sur chacun de
comprendre substituer chacun comprendra
qu'on ne change pas du jour au lendemain
des méthodes et des pratiques
d'interpellations lé rendez vous compte
métier quotidien des policiers et des
gendarmes ils ont besoin aussi d'être
rassurés sur leur capacité d'interpeller
c'est normal si une méthode est voué à
disparaître comme le propose le ministre
de l'intérieur il faut effectivement
qu'elle se remplacer ce remplacement ne
se fait pas un claquement de doigts n'en
déplaise à certains sénateurs ou madame
la sénatrice ça ne se fait pas comme ça
donc encore une fois en temps de crise
dans la situation que nous vivons
actuellement je crois que c'est mauvaise
polémique en faisant semblant de ne pas
comprendre comment fonctionne la vraie
vie dans les administrations le vrai
quotidien des policiers des gendarmes ne
me semble pas adéquat le ministre de
l'intérieur a bien répondu il a eu des
positions courageuses qui sont
difficiles je connais pas beaucoup
d'autres ministre de l'intérieur
honnêtement qui ont osé dire qu'il
pouvait y avoir des difficultés liées à
certaines prises certaines possibilités
d'interpellations par les policiers
gendarmes et se retrouve effectivement
dans des discussions complexes au sein
du ministère de l'intérieur
moi je te soutiens parce que je
considère que si ton discours était
courageux il est difficile à faire et ça
c'est un ministre qui comprend la
réalité du terrain et le rang saint
martin terminent avec des mesures de
sûreté votée par l'assemblée est destiné
aux ex détenus radicaliser
[Musique]
un terroriste en fin de peine pourra
bientôt avec son accord portait un
bracelet électronique à sa sortie de
prison ce dispositif fait partie de la
proposition de loi controversée diel
brune peavey présidente de la commission
des loi est votée cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale la ministre de la
justice nicole belloubet ci était
pourtant opposé les précisions de marion
becker les détenus condamnés pour
terrorisme devront désormais respecter
des mesures de sûreté à la fin de leur
peine
ainsi le juge d'application des peines
pourra leur imposer différentes
obligations jusqu'à cinq à dix ans après
leur sortie de prison
comme celle de pointer au commissariat
de police ou à la gendarmerie jusqu'à
trois fois par semaine ou encore le port
d'un bracelet électronique
cette disposition supprimée en
commission a été réintégrée contre
l'avis de la ministre
moi il me semble que ce bracelet ne
constitue pas nécessairement une
garantie supplémentaire ce n'est pas
parce que vous portez un bracelet que
pour autant vous ne pourrez pas
commettre tel ou tel acte à tel ou tel
moment il ne faut pas l'écarter parce
que c'est un moyen supplémentaire de
s'assurer de ses de ces individus bien
sûr que cette année lmnp un élément
essentiel même je dirais majeur de
protection
à gauche les communistes et les insoumis
ont exprimé leur opposition au texte
j'ai bien compris qu'il y avait la peur
j'ai bien compris que la peur était une
boussole mais elle est souvent mauvaise
conseillère
elle est très souvent mauvaise
conseillère donc je souhaite que que
l'on puisse retrouver retourner un peu à
la raison sur le sujet et qu'elle est
quelles sont les dimensions raisonnables
sur le sujet c'est que oui le temps de
la détention n'a pas été mis à profit
pour prévenir la récidive elle la
proposition de loi devrait permettre de
suivre les 5 114 détenus pour faits de
terrorisme à l'issue de leur peine
ainsi que les 769 mieux repérer comme
susceptible d'être radicaliser les
députés espère ainsi limiter le risque
de récidive et d'attentats laurent saint
martin quel est votre avis sur le
bracelet électronique vous êtes d'accord
et qui est le brunch iv ou avec la
ministre de la justice nicole belloubet
d'abord il ya urgence à agir sur les 500
détenus pour faits de terrorisme il y en
a 40
on sortir dans l'année donc quelqu'un on
a un sujet et chacun comprendra bien que
c'est un sujet à part et qu'il ya besoin
de ce suivi
après il ne fallait pas créer une peine
après la peine ce n'est pas cela la
justice française s'est cette fois c'est
le cas avec cette proposition de
compromis qui a été fait par gaëlle pour
une pie v qui permet effectivement
d'avoir de l'information d'avoir un
meilleur suivi
effectivement pour que au fur et à
mesure nous puissions les céline elles
veulent belloubet dit attentatoires aux
libertés
ce bracelet électronique je crois que
sur des faits exceptionnels comme ceux
de terrorisme nous devons nous assurer
ceinture et bretelles qu'il n'y pas de
risque de récidive
mais la garde et des français y fit qu'à
des français ne comprendraient pas ils
auraient raison qui puisse y avoir des
possibilités de récidive après des actes
de terrorisme
donc ce que proposait le privé est
intelligent c'est à dire que après la
peine
ce n'est plus la peine mais il y a
effectivement un suivi il ya une
possibilité si on accepte d'avoir ce
bracelet là de nous pointer qu'une fois
par semaine
donc c'est beaucoup moins atteints a
tantôt eu beaucoup moins une atteinte
pardon à la liberté individuelle que se
propose que proposait le groupe des
républicains mais c'est effectivement
une solution de compromis qui me paraît
si leur 1 samedi ont trouvé merci c'est
le mot de la fin
thème traduit merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]